For this problem, you can pick any value of x that lies between 1 and 2.
So I'm just going to show you an example of how you could have done this.
I'll pick the value 1.5, since that's right in the middle.
Now if I find the value of the function at x equals 1.5.
I'm actually finding f of 1.5, so I'll write that in here.
And if we plug 1.5 into our function for x, we end up with negative 1.3125.
Now we know that between x equals 1 and x equals 2,
our function goes from being negative to being positive. Since f of 1.5 is
negative, we know that this is now the new narrower lower bound of our interval.
So instead of the interval going from one to two the new narrow interval,
in which we know that the 0 lies is 1.5 to 2.